and then the Prime Minister has insisted
he'll put tackling corruption at the top
of the international agenda that's a
head of a major summit on the issue this
week political leaders businesses and
charities will gather in London with the
goal of signing a global anti-corruption
declaration among them will be the new
Secretary General of the Commonwealth
Baroness Patricia Scotland she's with me
now and a very good morning to you
Baroness Scotland now this is very
important for the Commonwealth visit
because I mean there are some
Commonwealth countries and territories
that are accused of facilitating money
laundering offshore funds tax evasion
and things like that what what can the
Commonwealth contribute to this was the
most important thing is to say that
unfortunately corruption affects every
single country in the world and the
Commonwealth's represents 53 countries
that's 2.2 billion people on one third
of the world's population but it's
really extraordinary how everyone now is
putting this issue right at the top of
their agenda not least because the
monies that would have been siphoned off
could have been used for to educate
children for health services and really
investing properly in the country so as
you may know what we are doing is having
a conference the day before the summit
to talk about what civil society can do
what businesses can do what governments
can do by working together because I
actually think the only way we're going
to tackle this is if we make it
everybody's business but as I say some
of the some of the countries in either
way where we're thinking of the recent
fury about offshore funds some of those
are Commonwealth territories now the
reasons why financial services grew in
those territories was because it was a
good way of getting money into those
economies if you take that away or
partially take it away from them there
have to be some form of compensation to
go into the schools and the hospitals
well I think the most important thing to
say is of course the overseas
territories are part of the British
territories the Commonwealth has a
number of terrorists who have used
financial services and have used them
robustly and well I think one of the
things that we are all knowing now is
that a new template is being created
there's this huge global debate between
avoidance and evasion we are concentrate
in the in the Commonwealth on the
illicit flows the monies which are
illegally unlawfully taken hidden away
and used in a way that's pernicious and
corrosive and corruptive so if you look
at the things that happened in the Arab
Spring for instance that was all about
corruption lyst about good governance it
was about the fact the rule of law
didn't work and he couldn't do anything
when people ripped you off we in the
Commonwealth know that we share common
law we share common language and we
believe there's an opportunity for us to
come together to have a common standard
using the common law and the common
language we have to build new and
effective tools to fight this because
the illicit are binding together they've
got their own conspiracy so we need a
conspiracy of the just so what we're
doing in the Commonwealth is we're going
to have a Commonwealth Office of
criminal and civil justice reform so be
honing those laws making those tools
sharing them but will also be trying to
create a Commonwealth standard so we can
differentiate between those companies
and entities who are trying as hard as
they can to comply with good practice
and those who aren't can I ask you about
a scholar at her how is the issue the
possibility of the UK leaving the
European Union how is that playing with
the Commonwealth I mean I've been
reading some Commonwealth countries
regarded to if Britain should leave the
EU as an opportunity for those
Commonwealth countries to do more trade
with the UK all I have actually been
hearing the opposite now firstly it's
matter entirely for the British people
to decide what they want to do and what
they don't want to do and it's their
decision and their decision alone but is
it causing some tensions within the
common well it's causing worry about
number of Commonwealth countries who
rely on Britain in Europe you have to
remember there are only four common law
countries in Europe at the moment that's
Island Cyprus Malta and Britain and
Britain is the biggest voice so for the
31 small countries within the
Commonwealth they rely on Britain to
speak up for them and you'll see a
number of countries saying they're
really worried that they're going to
lose
they're champion within the European
some major Commonwealth countries say
well because of immigration targets and
because at the moment being a member of
the EU and we have to allow anyone into
the country who is a member of a
European Union nation if that changed
then it would be easier for Commonwealth
countries for their peoples to access
the UK well I think this is really a
false dichotomy because if you look at
at the moment from a Commonwealth point
of view this is none of them a british
point of view it's not Commonwealth
point of view they have the best of both
worlds they've got a foot in Europe and
the foot in the Commonwealth and at the
moment there's a 19-percent advantage in
Commonwealth countries trading with each
other so if we could increase that good
hot enhance the things that join us we
could up that ninety percent advantage
but part of it is great because of
course we have the European market as
well as the Commonwealth market so I'm
afraid what I'm being told quite
strongly by Commonwealth countries is
that they think they've got the best of
both wheels at the moment and they'd
like to keep it but you know this matter
right yeah indeed it's just very quickly
on this issue of homosexuality and LBGT
rights it's a real issue isn't it for
the Commonwealth in that I mean the
estimation is ninety percent of conwell
populations live under the rule of some
countries that have some form of
criminalization of homosexuality do you
think you'll ever sort that out um well
we've got the Charter and you know this
is a process every single country who's
a member of the Commonwealth has their
own sovereignty and integrity but every
single country have committed to the
values contained in the Charter so are
we going to walk with them absolutely is
it going to be easy no but is it worth
doing absolutely and there are great
things that bind us together in the
Commonwealth and the most important is
we're a family we can stick together and
families don't always get on and they
don't always agree about everything but
at the end of the day they're a family
okay Baroness Scotland thank you very
much indeed very good to see the
secretary-general there of the
Commonwealth